ils sont venus de partout parmi eux
ils marchent ensemble même si les idées
sont différentes
sauver les océans arrêtez de manger de
la viande protéger la biodiversité
freiner l'utilisation des énergies
fossiles mais l'objectif est le même
éviter la catastrophe
[Musique]
c'est pour le meilleur et pour le pire
en robe de mariée symbole d'union
indéfectible à la nature qu'anastasia
fiq est venu marcher
la fermière du manitoba membres de
l'union nationale des fermiers veut
lancer un message clair aux décideurs
[Musique]
on n'a plus le temps là il veut tout
transit et justin en 2050 et là c'est
trop tard
anastasia vient parler au nom des
paysans et des autochtones qui eux n'ont
pas la chance de venir s'exprimer en
personne puis pour elle-même qui
travaille sur la terre et subit
directement les effets des changements
climatiques
la jeune femme a presque tout perdu
l'été dernier il y avait une grande
sécheresse cet été au manitoba qui a
commencé l'année dernière et ça va
continuer oui il n'y a pas de pluie et
les chants ont ils ont brûlé parce
qu'elle sait il faisait tellement chaud
accompagné de fermi du monde entier
comme ce jeune homme du pays basque ils
ont des solutions à proposer la
principale chose ça serait qu' on veut
pas de fausses solutions nous on est la
solution là c'est la souveraineté
alimentaire c'est la culture
l'agroécologie paysanne même s'ils sont
exaspérés par les dirigeants de ce monde
il a quand même espoir digne et frustré
mais en même temps on a donné un peu
d'espoir pour la suite parce qu'on sait
que haut niveau voilà au niveau local et
au niveau des populations on voit cette
marche aujourd'hui avec tout le monde
qui s'est réunie c'est une marche
immense pour pour les coches anastasia
mais aussi sur l'action citoyenne pour
changer les choses parce que pour
l'instant elle est déçue du gouvernement
canadien je suis fier des personnes
canadienne du gouvernement pas du tout
cette grande manifestation conclut la
première semaine de la coop 26 il reste
sept jours aux négociations sept jours
aux décideurs pour répondre et agir ici
et les intérêts radio-canada glasgow en
ecosse